who will talk about causal influence in
quantum theory so don't attend the floor
is yours
uh thank you very much um
thanks to the organizers and thanks for
the invitation and all that
um a great shame i can't be there looks
very nice
so so yes um
causal influence in in quantum theory is
what i'll be talking about
so there is by now a large literature on
classical causal models
and there's increasing interest in that
literature from from other communities
lots of machine learning and ai sorts of
people
talking about it these days and an
increasingly broad array of applications
whether it be automated medical
diagnosis or whatever
um
this literature also raises or perhaps
casts new light on more foundational
questions such as if a is a cause of b
then what sort of thing
are a and b what does it mean to say
that a is a direct cause of b
the causal concepts involve in an
essential way interventions by agents
causal relations directed in time
and what's in the overall picture is
ontic i.e factual and independent of any
agent and what is epistemic are you
relative to an agent's knowledge or
beliefs
now of course there's quite a literature
um addressing all of those kinds of
questions a lot of it is done just in
the classical case just assuming uh
our sort of everyday world of classical
things and and perhaps with classical
causal models in mind
but of course the classical world really
is emergent out of um the quantum world
um
physical systems in our world actually
obey the laws of quantum
theory so any um
full account that that answers these
kinds of questions should really um
start with quantum theory
and what i'm going to do is provide an
account of causal relations in quantum
and that you can see is asking and
answering some of these questions in
front of you quantum terms
um several things will come out of this
one is a quantum notion of causal model
that generalizes the sort of traditional
classical definition of a causal model
from which classical causal models are
then obtained as a special case
essentially when um quantum operators
are all diagonal
another thing that will come out which i
will get to if there's time we'll so
we'll see what happens it's so much more
speculative ideas
concerning uh new directions in in the
interpretation of quantum theory
so the talk is structured something like
this i'll start off talking about causal
influence
versus the concept of signaling
um
the idea of that discussion is that it
will motivate studying unitary
transformations in particular and so
i'll go on to discuss causal influence
through unitary transformations
then causal influence and unitary
processes which are built up of lots of
unitary transformations
then i'll come on to something i'll call
causally faithful circuit decompositions
and i'll explain what that means at the
time and as i said depending on how much
time left at the end speculative uh
remarks about interpretation of quantum
theory
so let's um so yes and i'm assuming
finite dimensional systems throughout
and really haven't thought that much
about um
possible generalizations to infinite
dimensional systems so i'm just assuming
finite dimensions for now
so let's talk about causal influence and
also signaling and we're going to start
just with something classical so i'm
considering here a classical function
that i've represented in a sort of
circuit notation as as a gate
the gate corresponds to a function f and
it has two inputs x and lambda
which in this example are going to be
classical bits and it's got one output z
which is also a classical bit
and we're going to suppose that z
is
simply the parity of x and lambda that
is z equals x plus lambda mod 2.
okay and suppose that lambda is somehow
hidden
and that from some agent's point of view
they give a probability to lambda being
naught and a probability to lambda being
one and let's suppose that those
probabilities are a half each
well then
we can talk about the marginal channel
from x to z the channel that we get by
marginalizing over lambda
well in that channel the output z is
completely random of course and
independent of x
so what this means is that from the
point of view of an agent who doesn't
know the value of lambda and assigns
those probabilities
there is no signaling from x to z
someone
if if that agent is is deliberately
intervening on x fixing it to be naught
or one
um
then the the value that said is
independent of that
but
what we should say here is that
independently of any agent there is
causal influence from x to z because
once you see the full picture with the
lambda there as well you see that in the
function f set does indeed depend on the
value of x it depends on both x and
lambda
so
this is an instance of of what's often
called fine tuning
we do indeed have causal influence from
extra zed
but when we when we marginalize over
lambda we don't see
signaling
uh but this only happens for that very
particular distribution on lambda
half-half
for other distributions on lambda you
would still see signaling from x to z
we can describe a very similar example
in the quantum case
so here again i've got him
a a small circuit this is a c naught
gate
it's got two qubits as its input a and
lambda controls on a
um i put a little symbol on b there
which indicates that we're just tracing
out b
we're not going to be interested in that
one
and and the other output is c
now suppose that what's happening is
that
someone tosses a coin
and then prepares the zero state of
lambda if it's heads and the one state
of its tails
well then let's assume a fair coin to an
agent unaware of the value of the
outcome of that coin toss they'll assign
a state to lambda which is a mixed state
ion2
and then you can marginalize over that
lambda system and look at the resulting
channel from a to c
and from that agent's perspective
there's no signaling from a to c
and this is an instance of fine tuning
again because with other values of rho
lambda you would see signaling from a to
c
and again there clearly is causal
influence here from a to c indeed from
another agent's perspective who knows
the value of the coin toss a signal can
indeed be set
so what do we take away from this brief
discussion well we should conclude in
both classical and quantum cases that
causal influence should not be defined
by signaling
and signaling
is an epistemic notion so whether alice
can signal to bob depends on what both
of them know
or even in more general examples on
things like what alice knows about what
bob knows
and so on
so let's ask the question in a quantum
universe what then is a good notion of
causal influence
distinct from just the idea from of
signaling through a general channel
and i'm going to argue as follows
although fine-tuned unobserved systems
can result in an absence of apparent
signaling
causal influence can be defined once all
relevant systems are included in the
description
so that happened in the classical case
once we included lambda and and
and saw the function f
as a function of both um
the other input and lambda then we saw
that the outputs um
was influenced by the other input and
similarly for the quantum example with
the c naught
now when all relevant systems are
included in the description we're now
dealing with a closed system and at
least in standard quantum theory closed
systems evolve unitarily
i'm not going to deal with more
speculative ideas wherein the
fundamental quantum evolution is is some
kind of cp map rather than a unitary i'm
just sticking to standard quantum theory
here where closed systems do evolve
unitarily
and so
what we get out of this argumentation is
that causal influence should be defined
in terms of unitary transformations
okay so let's do that
um this is just some notation on this
slide
uh so consider a quantum channel with
input a and output b corresponding to
some trace preserving cp map e
then the state at the output row b could
be written that's the cp map e applied
to the input state row a
that cp map will have a choi gem
alkowski isomorphic operator
which i'll take to be given by an
expression like this that can be
different conventions here so in a way
i'm showing you what conventions i'm
using a star is a dual space to a
and the reason for choosing these
particular conventions is that this way
the operator which i write as row with a
subscript b given a is a positive
operator
um and if we trace out the b system on
that operator we just get the identity
um acting on a star
okay so i'll be writing operators like
this sometimes representing channels
some row and and then
outputs of the channel given input of
the channel
okay and now we'll make a definition
of causal influence through a unitary
transformation
so we consider a generic bipartite
unitary transformation u
with input say b and output cd
well we'll say that a does not influence
d
if
the following condition holds
for all
inputs
rho b
if i trace out c and just look at the
marginal state
on d at the output then that marginal is
independent of row a
there are actually a whole slew of
different definitions that you could
make here but they're all equivalent
is the nice thing so here's one of them
equivalently if i consider the choi
jamalkowski operator for that unit tree
and trace out c
then it ends up having a certain form
which is the operator row cd given a b
with c traced
just turns into row of d given b where
that's some channel from b to d tends
with identity on a
um
this is related to signaling of course
this definition
um
another way of saying it is that
if you trace out c
then
roughly there's no signaling from a to d
um but importantly that's asserted
not just for a particular input at the
state b but but there's a quantification
it's for all
states uh on the input b there is no
signaling from a to d so that is another
equivalent way of um
stating it
um but i wouldn't necessarily want to
take that way of stating it as the most
fundamental because it appeals to
signaling which is bound up with agents
and things
and
the way i see the story that i'm telling
here um
it's it's not necessarily one that takes
things like agents and signaling and
things that agents do to be fundamental
here
okay
and a little more notation
so if a in fact does influence d then
we'll sometimes write it this way a with
just a sort of double arrow into d
and if a does not influence d a with the
arrow crossed out into d
all right
and now i'm going to state a a
theorem about unitary transformations
and i'm calling this the uber theorem
um
because most of the rest of what i'm
going to say follows from this theorem
in one way or another some of the things
i'll say follow immediately from this
theorem and and some
um
not immediately but with a bit of
further work
um
but nonetheless follow from it in some
way
so the uber theorem is this
let's consider some unitary
transformation with inputs a1 a2 up to a
k
outputs b1 b2 up to bn
um
for each of those outputs
i can define the subset of inputs which
do influence it
and i'll call those inputs the parents
of that particular output
um
so let's
pa subscript i
then
be the set of parents for the output bi
so that is it's a set of inputs aj such
that aj does influence
the output bi
and here's the end of the statement of
the theorem if we write down the choi
jamalpowski operator for that unitary
transformation
um here it is
so that's rho for the unitary
transformation u
outputs b one to be n given inputs a one
to a k
that george mulkowski operator takes a
certain special form
which it's that it's a product
of operators
one for each output bi
and where each of those terms is a
channel
um it's the troy jamal kowski operator
for some channel from the parents
of that output bi into bi
where furthermore all of those terms
commute so in the in the product it
doesn't matter which which order i write
them in
okay
well i'm not going to prove that now but
um
but it's it's true
and we're going to use this to do things
um
a little convention here quite often i
write down a product of operators that
appear to act on on different hilbert
spaces and people might then wonder well
how is it even defined
and the idea is you sort of pad with
tensor products with identities anytime
you need to in order to make products of
operators well defined
okay
so i'll say straight away a couple of
consequences of this uber theorem
one is a thing that i'm calling causal
atomicity which is the following
statement
if i have this this unitary
transformation suppose that one of the
inputs say i does not influence one of
the outputs bj
and also that same input ai does not
influence another one of the outputs b k
well if i combine b and j and b k
together
and regard them as um as a composite
system just one system on its own
then it also follows that ai does not
influence that composite system
bjbk
so this this is essentially um
immediate i think given the uber theorem
note that this is true for for unitary
channels and if we were discussing
classical functions
uh we could also discuss causal
influence through a classical function
and then trivially this same statement
would be true
um
yeah if a given input x is not
influencing output y for a function and
not z either then pretty trivially it's
not influencing the classical variable
defined as the pair
of um
of our fairway and said
and however a statement like this is not
true in general if we're discussing
signaling through a cp map or in the
classical case a general stochastic map
so in that case it can very well happen
that an influence sorry an input doesn't
influence some output
and not another one either but does
influence the pair
um
for i mean just think of an input being
a classical bit
you you can have its value written into
the parity of of two of the outputs
which are both locally random for
instance
in which cases
not signaling to either of them on their
own
so something follows from this causal
atomicity which is that there's a
certain simplicity to the causal
structure of a unitary transformation
because that causal structure can be
completely specified by those parental
sets
we just need to consider each output on
its own and specify its parents amongst
the inputs and once i've done that i've
completely specified the causal
structure of a unit tree
which means graphically something nice i
can draw that causal structure just by
drawing errors from inputs individual
inputs to individual outputs i'll draw
an arrow whenever an input does in fact
influence a particular output
for general cp maps or classical
stochastic maps this wouldn't be true
and i couldn't represent the causal
structure just by drawing simple arrows
in this way i'd have to have a more
complicated picture where i think about
arbitrary subsets of the inputs and
arbitrary subsets of the outputs
okay here's another consequence of that
uber theorem thing
um this i'll call causal reversibility
so if i consider a particular unitary
transformation that again that one with
inputs a128k
and outputs b1 to bn i can draw its
causal structure with these arrows
well to get the causal structure of the
inverse unit for u minus one
i just flip the arrows
um so here's the um
inverse u minus one it has inputs we're
reading top to bottom now so it has
inputs v1 to bn and outputs a1 to ak
and to get its causal structure i just
draw the causal structure of u which is
here and flip those arrows
now in case anyone thought that was
obvious it
it's not so obvious and it's actually
stronger than the mere claim that
unitaries are reversible transformations
in fact
it's not true for classical functions
it's not even true for classical
reversible functions
um the classical c not gate is an
example of a classical reversible
function which which is actually a
counter example there
um so so it's it's it's more special
than just the claim that unitaries are
reversible
transformations
something similar does hold if
we're not considering all classical
reversible functions but rather
classical synthetic transformations on
phase spaces
so you do get a similar kind of claim if
it's classical mechanics that you're
thinking about
okay
now let's turn to consider
quantum processes
uh rather than just a single unitary
transformation so here's an example of a
process it's got some initial inputs
lambda 1 to k and outputs mu 1 to mu n
and it's a process consisting of a bunch
of unitary transformations
um
i've drawn this for the general case not
every unitary transformation has to act
on all
systems this would look a bit more like
a sort of conventional quantum circuit
if if u1 for instance was only acting on
a couple of the systems and u2 and only
on a different couple of systems and and
so on
um so i'm just being general by allowing
each of these unitary transformations to
act on all systems they don't have to
now we're going to break some of the
wires you can see i've done that in the
picture and i've labeled those breaks a
b c and d
so what does a broken wire correspond to
well i'll call it the quantum node
and the idea is that we think of one of
these quantum modes as a kind of locus
within the process
at which we can consider an additional
possible evolution of the system
so i i don't want to emphasize the role
of agents here too much for reasons i
said earlier
but sometimes pedagogically it's kind of
helpful to mention them so if you like
you can think of an agent stationed at
that point in the circuit
and that agent is able at that point to
do an intervention on the system a
measurement or an extra little unitary
transformation if they want to
so one of these
loci will be associated with two hilbert
spaces one with the bottom part
of the broken wire and one with the top
part
um so for the node a for example i'll
label these h a and h a out
and the most general thing an agent
could do there would be described by a
quantum instrument that then mediates
this incoming hilbert space and the
outgoing hilbert space and the whole
thing here um is an example of something
that's been studied quite a bit in the
literature under different sorts of
names sometimes these are called super
maps sometimes quantum cones
amongst other things
so what i want to do is define a causal
structure
for these quantum nodes
and in order to do that we don't have to
do very much we just
stretch the wires
so if we look at the what was the the a
node here
you can see
that the
outgoing wire the top part of the broken
wire
associated with the a node has sort of
been stretched down to the bottom of the
diagram and is still labeled with a out
and the uh the incoming wire for that
anode has been stretched right up to the
top of the diagram and is still labeled
with a in
and same for b c and d here
[Music]
and the reason for doing this is that
that when you do that
with your picture you see that the
overall unitary process can be thought
of this way it actually corresponds to
in fact is identical with
just one big unitary transformation v
whose inputs are all the things that
were at the bottom here
so a out b out c out and so on and whose
outputs are all the things at the top
here so it's a and b and and so on
along with the muse
and now we can define
direct cause relations in our process
by appealing to the definition we
already have for a unit tree and
applying it to v
so we're going to say that in this
process a node x where in the example x
might be any of a b c d or one of the
initial inputs lambda i
we'll say that that node x is a direct
cause of another node y
if and only if
x out
influences y in in this unitary
transformation v
and some things then follow from the
causal atomicity i was talking about
um that's the thing that ensured that if
you just have one unitary transformation
you can represent its causal structure
with arrows from inputs to outputs
from that it follows that the causal
relations in this whole process can be
represented by a directed acyclic graph
and it's important to understand that
that follows from causal atomicity it's
it's not completely trivial
that it that the directed acyclic graph
is the right mathematical object for
representing causal relations here but
it does follow otherwise you might have
just been thinking about a partial order
something weaker like that
but actually they're represented by a
direct delay cyclic graph
and there's a sneak thing of causal
symmetry which shows that the causal
structure of the inverse process
is given by flipping the arrows
okay
from the uber theorem it follows that
the operator sigma representing the
supermap
can now be written
as a product of commuting channels
where
in that product we have a
channel for each node that appears in
the dag
and it's a channel from the parents of
that node in the dag into
the input space for that node
and all of those channels commute
all right i'm going to skip that bit
and come on to the idea of causally
faithful circuit decompositions
can i ask um how much longer have i got
yes
you have
15 minutes
okay okay
so here's
what this next bit is going to be about
the commutation
of the operators in the uber theorem
induces tensor factor and direct sum
decompositions
of the hilbert spaces in interesting and
intricate ways
and the reason i want to show you this
bit is that it's really here i think
that we see what causal
relations in quantum theory are all
about
and and the structure of causal
relations in quantum theory it's really
to do
with these tensor factor and direct sum
decompositions of hilbert spaces
i'm going to explain what i mean by
starting with a couple of quite simple
examples
so let's consider again just a bipartite
unitary transformation
you'll have inputs a1 and a2 and outputs
b1 and b2
and let's suppose that for this unitary
transformation it happens
that
a1 does not influence b2
and also a2 does not influence b1
well then something follows actually
immediately from that uber theorem which
is that this unitary transformation can
be written
as a direct product of two unitary
transformations
v and w where v is just a unitary
transformation from a1 to b1 and w from
a2 to
b2 the nice thing about writing
the picture that way is that it makes
the causal structure explicit in the
diagram
so once you've written it this way it's
obvious that a1 doesn't influence b2
just because there's no path from a1 to
b2
through this circuit
let's look at um another example
let's consider a tripartite unitary now
it's got inputs a1 a2 a3 and outputs b1
b2 b3 and we're going to suppose that a1
does not influence b3 here
and a3 does not influence b1
so actually a2 is the only thing that
does influence both of b1 and b3
so it's playing the role of a sort of
complete common cause here
for
b1 and b3
so we're going to ask a similar question
can the causal structure of this unitary
be made evident by decomposing you into
a circuit
well if it could then the circuit would
have to look like this one here
with unitary transformations s v w and t
so you can see that this circuit does
have the right structure it's evident
that a1 does not influence b3 because
there's no path from a1 to b3
through this circuit and similarly from
a3 to b1
and but the answer to our question is no
unfortunately at least some specific
unitaries might admit for circuit like
that but in not in general
however we can do something
else it turns out that any unitary with
these indicated no influence conditions
can be written with a kind of extended
circuit diagram that looks like this
you'll see it looks a bit like a normal
quantum circuit but it's got these
indices appearing this index i that
appears on some of the wires
and also the gates
these gates are still unitary
transformations
and in this picture it's a again the
case that there's no path from a1 to b3
so that's nice because it makes explicit
that a1 cannot influence b3
so what do these indices mean
well in a conventional circuit diagram
each wire corresponds to a hilbert space
and if i have two parallel wires that
correspond to the tensor product
of the two hilbert spaces
the way this diagram works is that
these two wires in parallel which have
both got eye on them
um
correspond to
a direct sum
indexed by i
where each term in the direct sum is a
tensor product of two hilbert spaces
and so we look at if we look at the
slice corresponding to this red dotted
line that size corresponds to an overall
hilbert space which is
h a1 that's just the hilbert space
corresponding to the a1 wire that
doesn't have an index
tensor
the thing corresponding to these two
parallel wires with eyes on them
um which is going to be isomorphic to
the hilbert space ha2
and has the structure that i described
and and then tends to another hilbert
space for this wire a3
okay
and the point here is that a theorem
says that any unit tree with these no
influence conditions
can be
decomposed into a circuit an extended
circuit
represented by a diagram like this
and this idea generalizes so here's just
a bit of a fancier example
this is a unitary transformation with
four inputs and four outputs
um
this sort of little thing on the left is
supposed to indicate the um
causal relations
so there's an output b2
whose parents are just a1 and a3 and b2
is not influenced by a2 or a4
that's why b2 is in red here and there's
a red
oval around a1 and a3 here
um similarly output b1 is
not influenced by a4 but is influenced
by the other three
and so on so that's how this picture on
the left summarizes the causal relations
and then the claim is that any unitary
that has four inputs and four outputs
and has those causal relations can be
decomposed into an extended circuit that
looks like this
where the circles are unitary
transformations
and you can see again that some of the
wires
have got indices on them um
representing
sort of direct surman and
um combinations of smaller hilbert
spaces
it's an open question whether any
multipartite unitary transformation
emits a causally faithful decomposition
like this we have lots of examples where
it does
we have a general result that says if
there's
at most three inputs and any number of
outputs then there's a causally faithful
decomposition um
similarly at most three outputs in any
number of inputs
but it is an open question whether you
can always find one in general
and i'll just say again causally
faithful here means that you've drawn an
extended circuit like this
where
there's a path from an input to an
output if and only if the input causally
influences the output
okay and now i'm just going to sort of
draw everything together
and that'll be it except for the
speculative bit at the end
the above discussion about causally
faithful circuit decompositions applies
whether the unitary transformation being
decomposed is associated with evolution
just over two time steps say t1 for the
inputs and t2 for the outputs
or whether it's obtained from a
multi-step process by stretching the
wires that is that the big unitary
transformation v
that we had earlier
which represents a supermap
corresponding to the process
so putting everything together
we get a picture that looks something
like this we might start off with a
unitary process like this one
where some of the wires are broken
those are the loci of interest if you
like the ones for which we decided to be
interested in their causal relations
and so this one has some original inputs
as well lambda 1 lambda 2 and outputs
mu1 and mu2
starting with this diagram for this
process with with gaps in it broken
wires
we stretch the wires
okay so there's that same process with
wires stretched up to the top and bottom
there's a corresponding big unitary
transformation v
which in this case would have a out b
out as its inputs along with lambda 1
lambda 2 and a and b and as it outputs
along with mu1 and mu2
we can define the causal structure of v
that is for each of the outputs of b we
can say what subset of inputs is it
influenced by and we can represent that
structure just by drawing arrows
so just as an example here's how it
might look for some particular v
then
that causal structure
we might be able to draw a causally
faithful extended circuit diagram
um
now if you can always do that then we'll
always be able to do it for v but as i
said that's an open question
but actually this one that i've drawn
here that's one that we do know how to
draw an extended circuit diagram for so
any v with this causal structure can be
written as an extended circuit that
looks like this
and then by unstretching the wires so by
unstretching them i mean we sort of bend
them around again so that
this a out bit here is again just on top
of the a index so it looks like a single
wire with a gap
and b out here is just on top of the b
in bit so it just looks like a single
wire with a gap
i can achieve that without changing this
diagram in any way except sort of
bending wires a little bit and we end up
with this picture here which is an
extended circuit diagram for that
original unit process
that i uh drew
and then that will have a causal
structure um determined by that the
causal structure of that unitary
transformation v which in the example
i'm doing looks like this and this
picture which is a unitary circuit
diagram
is causally faithful in the sense that
any node in this picture
if it's
a direct cause of another node in this
structure
then there is a path
from our first node to our second node
in this circuit that does not traverse
any other nodes
if we traversed another node it would be
an indirect causing
influence
okay
i will finish off
with those speculative
interpretive remarks
um
this is
okay so we've seen already that there's
a lot of sort of structure involved an
interesting structure at that when you
start looking at causal relations
amongst different points and unitary
processes
um and and i hope that this will lead to
a useful way of doing quantum causal
modelling but much as classical causal
modeling has turned out to be useful
with all kinds of practical applications
but let's um let's go in the direction
of foundations instead
let's just roll with the idea that
causal structure is ontic meaning
out there in the world independent of
agents
um so so one way that could be true is
that unitary evolution is in fact ontake
unitary's aren't
in which case the causal structure of
those unit trees is also on tick it
could also be something a bit weaker
somehow the unit trees themselves are
not onto but merely the causal structure
of those unitaries that could be a
possibility
okay and rolling with this let's suppose
that in any quantum experiment
in which we would normally say that a
measurement device has a pointer and
each time you do it the pointer goes
left or right
let's suppose the measurement device can
be modeled entirely as a quantum system
as we ought to
well then let's suppose that we can
describe the entire experiment as a
overall unitary process
that in that process there are causal
relations as i've described them
and that you can represent that process
then with an extended circuit diagram
which is causally faithful for that set
of causal relations
and that diagram will typically have
these indices on it
and denoting sort of uh subspaces or
orthogonal decompositions of hilbert
spaces
and the speculation is that facts that
obtain on an individual trial eg pointer
went left
correspond to indices in that diagram
taking definite values
like an index i on that trial took the
value 0
rather than the value 1 or whatever
this could be cashed out in various
different ways for example you could try
and turn it into a new kind of hidden
variable theory
where the theory the hidden variable is
an assignment of definite values to each
of those indices
and the theory itself would be defined
by some way of
ascribing a joint distribution
over those index values for for any
given
experiment any given extended circuit
a slightly different way of caching out
the idea would be something more like
ravelli's relational qm
somehow indices take definite values but
only relative to other systems
or even something everett like wherein
um
there's a world where i takes value zero
in a world where i takes value one a
world where pointer went left in a world
where points went right but here would
be that worlds are defined by the causal
structure within the seasons of
distinguished by different values
of those indices
all right and that's pretty much all
i've got to say
um
i've got a blank slide here with
conclusions written on it i suppose in a
way that conclusions
are just to go right back to some of
these questions at the beginning
and uh
say how each of these questions are
answered by the account that i've given
but maybe rather than talk through all
that now
i will simply stop
and see if there's any questions or
anything
thanks
okay thanks a lot
[Applause]
so we have one question
i uh this is a maybe a very basic
question but when you did the causely
faithful
representation and you introduced the
direct sum of uh terms indexed by i what
what what determines the cardinality of
i
there
um the the it's the unitary itself that
you are decomposing
so
where's uh
so in any given particular example
these systems will all have definite
dimensions
and it'll be some particular choice of
unitary that you're decomposing
there isn't some simple relation between
those dimensions
um
not really in general i mean for example
there exists tripartite unitaries as i
said where you actually can draw a
picture like this one here
um
where the eyes don't appear which is
kind of the same as saying there is an
eye and it but it only has cardinality
of one
um
but then there'll be other choices of of
this tripartite unit tree where where i
i have to draw a picture with with an
eye
and then the number of
distinct values that i needs to range
over it just just varies depending on
the the unit tree i'm decomposing
i mean it never needs to vary over more
than the dimension of the system
and one other quick question your last
slide in four with lambda and mu
is there a direction in that uh
in the diagrams where you had the the
circles that yes that kind of diagram is
there an implicit direction there from
the bottom to the top or
um
so a nice thing here is that so i i mean
i'm reading the figure from bottom to
top and i'm considering a unitary
transformation that has inputs a1 to a4
and outputs b1 to b4
um
but you could also consider the um the
inverse of that unitary transformation
and it would have inputs b1 to b4 and
outputs a1 to a4
and there's this causal symmetry
property i talked about so you would get
its causal structure just by inverting
the arrows
and then that inverse unitary could be
presented by a picture that looks like
this but read from top to bottom
so actually i also have a question about
the slide you just had before with this
uh different eyes and this tensor
product so maybe you said it in your
conclusion but i i did not get it
is there a way to
maybe physically interpret what this
formula means
do you have
i don't know selection rules
stuff like this
with the formula here i mean yes yes yes
yes so if i have for instance
i let's say i equals zero and one what
what does it mean physically can i say
something
i guess so well is this in connection
with with the speculation i was making
or are we not worrying about that for
now and you're just asking me about
the diagrams
well just in the diagrams yes if you
have such a decomposition with let's say
two different eyes
okay how can
can i associate uh
let's say can i associate a concrete
physical interpretation
of the way i decompose the unitary
um
i guess one let me say a little more in
case it helps one one thing that i
didn't explain very much
is what this vi here is it's a gate i
said i said it's a unity transformation
um but you have to give an
interpretation as a sort of semantics
for this type of diagram
in in which
you see this this gate
it crosses this wire here one of its
inputs is this wire and one of its
inputs is this wire here with an eye on
it but it doesn't cross this wire here
which um which also has an eye on it
so and and i've written vi inside this
box so what does that mean
it means that there's a unitary
transformation there v which is really a
unitary transformation of both of a1 a2
it's just that that unitary
transformation is blocked diagonal with
respect to the decomposition indicated
by i
and inside each block that unitary
transformation b
only acts on this term here the um the
left turn the one associated with this
wire and its identity on the right term
here
um so it's i physically you could say
it's telling us something about the way
this
a2 system is interacting with the a1 and
the a3 systems
um it's saying that the a2 hilbert space
decomposes into a direct sum of
orthogonal subspaces but then inside
each of those orthogonal subspaces
you've got this factorization into two
bits
and a one only interacts with one of
those bits and a three only interacts
with the other one of those bits
i think that's the best i can say in
this sort of quite general setting in
actual physical examples of course
um
you know we wouldn't just be talking
about abstract systems but
sort of ions or whatever and these unit
trees with it would actually correspond
to specific interactions and then
therefore we could say things about them
okay and you can say something which is
related to what you just said
at a quite high level
yeah
okay
so i i think we uh sorry
thanks thanks for the lovely talk john
um i'm just interested in the
distinction between the causal influence
and causal signaling that you made at
the start
so the two examples that you gave the
the c naught gate for the quantum case
and
the example for the classical case
so the way i would think of it is in
both cases
you can actually
uncover what's going on as long as you
have
um apt control so once you can get in
and vary those parameters you can see
what the kind of true
um or you know what what the causal
story is that's underlying that fine
tuning you can kind of
see why it's fine-tuned
so in that instance it seems like you do
kind of need signaling to make that
distinction um
and if you want if you want to posit
that they are actually in fact different
things then
then it would seem that you you ought
not to be able to
to um
discover uh you know
the physical situation through
um interventions and if that's the case
then you're kind of positing a causal
influence that you can never know you
can never discover
so i just i'm a bit confused about why
why there is that distinction
um
so i i
i think i just agree with you actually
so um
i don't think there's a
disagreement between us there um
so that with this classical example here
um
i i suppose really i was tilting at a
certain attitude you see that one finds
in sort of lots of
papers um
specifically from sort of in the quantum
information community where people talk
a good deal about causal this and cause
all that
but pretty much just define causal
influence as signaling through a general
channel
um just in an operational kind of way
and and when you do that
um
you don't
sort of bring out this this distinction
between
um
between there being no causal influence
and and they're being signaling washed
out by fine-tuning
so
in in this example here that the point
is supposed to be that there is
causal influence from x to z
and for a function you know you can
understand that very easily it just
means that in the function z does have
some
functional dependence on x
as well as orlando in this example
um
and of course that that's a that is
equivalent to saying that
for at least some distributions over
lambda you can signal from x to z
so
we we can say that causal influence is
signaling here if we want to
um
but only once you've
and only once you've got the full
picture which involves the function f
and the variable lambda
so
i think we also have
questions online
okay uh i
maybe the people online can directly ask
them
can i can i ask a question
um so john thanks after talking that was
interesting um so one question is
you start out with an unitary without
with some circuit that without the
broken wires right and then at some
point you break some ice and stretch
them out
and then you ask well can i give
a causally faithful
decomposition of the resulting imagery
after stretching the whites and then in
some cases you find you can
is there a guarantee but but then you
could you could choose instead to break
some other wires
rather than the ones you picked up at
first and then you would get some
other industry between different hybrid
spaces which maybe would get a different
quasi graph
with a different kind of decomposition
um is there a guarantee that there's so
that there's some consistency between
the graphs if you choose to break this
industry in different ways or if you
start by breaking one way and they won't
get one graph but now what if i now keep
breaking some other errors is there some
guarantee that it's going to be a
consistency between the graphs or could
it be that you get completely different
composition that it can't match
to somehow being part of the same graph
um
i mean i i think there'll be a guarantee
of as much consistency as one should
require
um
what um
so any causal talk at all and this is
true in both the quantum and the
classical cases
is relative to
how we've decided to carve up the world
into different bits
and which of those bits have we decided
to be particularly interested in and
which are we ignoring
um
so to even talk about unitaries with
multiple inputs you've made a decision
about how to factor some big system into
multiple inputs
um but but all of this is true um
in
in any kind of causal stories as i said
even classically as well
um
like if uh
if i'm considering a coin tossed on
earth and another coin tossed on mars i
might judge that they're independent and
assign a probability distribution that
factorizes
sort of based on reichenbach's principle
or something that's that's what i do
and might have a whole you know that
might form the basis of some old causal
story
of course if i decide to do something
weird and then decide that one of my
systems of interest is the parity of
those two coins
and then the other system i don't know
just the earth coin on its own like just
factor the whole thing completely
differently in some weird way
you're going to end up with a just a
different causal story
and it's not just how to factor things
it's the questions of course screening
coming into it as well
um
and and and which presumably i'm not
considering all of the universe at once
most of the time i'm doing causal
reasoning so there's a decision about
which bits to ignore
so i think the right way to see it is
that any kind of causal talk is relative
to a particular way of
carving up the world and deciding what
we're interested in
and there can even be a sort of um
anthropocentric uh element there you
know how we've decided to carve things
up might be relative to our own
interests
um
but i i think
with that proviso it's still right to
see causal relations as antique
just because it's relative to our
interests it doesn't make everything
sort of epistemic in the way that
probabilities are
um so you're quite right in a way you'll
end up with different sorts of stories
that depending on where you put the gaps
in your circuit
or even if you factor things differently
into a different circuit but i think
that's to be
expected
okay so uh we are all the time i think
there is still a question online but i
propose that uh
like you discuss it uh
online uh we'll make a very short break
and uh
i don't know how much time we have just
a
glass of water time
okay thanks a lot
[Applause]